it's at least possible
that uh the fear of death the terror of
your mortality is the creative force
that created all of the things around us
at this human civilization
and i think about from an engineering
perspective
this is where i lose all of my robotics
colleagues
is i feel like
if you want to create intelligence you
have to also
engineer in some kind of
echoes of this kind of fear of uh and
not you know fear is such a complicated
word but
kind of like a scarcity
a scarcity of time a scarcity of
resources
that creates a kind of anxiety like
deadlines get you to do stuff yeah and
there's something almost fundamental to
that in terms of uh
human experience yeah well that's an
interesting thought so you're basically
in order to
create
a kind of
structure that mirrors what we call
consciousness yes you better have that
structure confront the same kinds of
issues and terrorism
that we do consciousness and suffering
only makes sense in the context of death
if you want to i feel like
if you want to fit into human society
if you if you're a robot if you want to
fit into human society you better have
the same kind of existential dread
the same kind of fear of mortality
otherwise you're not going to fit in
it might be it might be wild but it's at
least like we're talking about all the
theories that
are at least worth consideration i think
that's a really powerful one and
definitely one has uh resonated with me
and um
definitely seems to capture something
beautifully
like real about the human condition
and i i wonder it's of course sucks to
think that we need death
to appreciate life
um
but uh that just may be the way it is
well it's interesting if this robotic or
artificially intelligent system
understands the world and understands
the second law of thermodynamics and
entropy
even in artificial intelligence will
realize that
even if its parts are really robust
ultimately it will disintegrate yeah i
mean so the time skills may be different
but in a way when you think about it
doesn't matter once you know that you
are mortal in the sense that you are not
eternal the time scale hardly matters
it's it's either the whole thing or not
because on the scales of eternity any
finite duration however large is
effectively zero
on the scales of eternity and so maybe
it won't be so hard for an artificial
system to feel that sense of mortality
because it will recognize the underlying
physical laws and recognize its own
finitude
and it'll be us and robots drinking
beers looking up at the stars and just
uh
you know
having a good laugh in awe of the whole
thing yeah
i think that's a pretty good way to end
it talking about the fear of death we
started
talking about the meaning of life and
ended on the fear of death brian it's
just an incredible confidence pleasure
thank you
i really really enjoyed it it's been a
long time coming i'm a huge fan of your
work a huge fan of your writing thanks
for talking about thank you
you